what app that I use the most I use post
me is probably the most just post made
stupid [ __ ] condoms not to Apple remote
I post made to Apple remotes just
popping this Tiger and these are my
citrus all right first up iPhone
definitely essential shall know what I
would do it out the phone you know I'm
saying really she's everything you know
I'm saying like all the information you
need that I'm communicating with people
I'm saying Instagram Twitter
I took Apple music Spotify Google email
FaceTime everything ways definitely
important essential everyday essentially
have no I'm saying I like style padding
up against definitely my favorite
watching right now cuz it stand it's
like or you know I'm saying is get the
job done but it's crazy I don't use it
to tell time I probably haven't used the
watch to tell time like probably never
you know I'm saying this is straight
from paddock anything is possible with
money right this watches fire if you
want to see my other ones check out my
last video another everyday essential
freaking a jury is a my custom or
lifestyle Cuban it's about like two
kilos may be super heavy super long to
this is like every day I'm a custom
piece that I put on it but sometimes too
heavy hurts my neck you gotta wear like
a towel or as you leave your neck gets
like well turning [ __ ] so I'll try not
to wear the piece is not super special
and I'll just like where to change it's
on the lock
it's just across
you know to protect I get all costs
you know me shoutout to my children
being bother you know he does some of
the best jury in the world you know I'm
saying
no funny diamonds all clean or GI a
certified tell me AER pots you know I
always lose them I'm always getting new
ones but you know when you're on the
plane anywhere in the gym even in the
car like you know I mean so I have so
many like right years left years just
all over the place but I always like get
a new pair all the time I'm always
forgetting things I might forget my
phone passport sometime you know so much
[ __ ] going on man you know sometimes we
think about it
shoutout to post make shout outs a
person that got these along with my two
Apple remotes
say I got a little 10% tip at the end
little back a little man back you don't
say I got some gum in here some
chapstick maybe put cash put your iPhone
charger it's just uh little things that
you can't fit in your pocket I said the
or one we always switch it up different
brands but today we back them with the
name of goofy your joint and I'm saying
we're here I'm saying put whatever you
want in there no pain ropes no pain
you don't cash whatever you know say you
got to keep your day-to-day stuff in one
place another essential right here my
charge portable iPhone charger you know
them an accident even girls all day
thanks not know but like them apps that
should burn your battery out you know
I'm saying like I think Instagram takes
up like 70% of your battery or something
like that so it's always good to have
like one of these on deck and you put
this in your little little do your bag
and blew me right you good to go right
on the go oh yeah and we flies me fly
international it's good too because you
go to adapters you're gonna do buy or go
to certain places outlets are different
so it's always good when you can just
charge your phone up I'm gonna go
I don't know this will probably get lost
by the end of this trip so these right
here these are definitely go to see I
got the red pair on right now switch it
out Randy white he's up movie Tom
millionaires I'm by Virgil and you know
these is just like go-to glass thing I
got every color shout-out to virgin when
he killed it with these and it's crazy
because it's like that it's an updated
version of the original ones that Marc
Jacobs did the original millionaires and
I got every color knows to so you know
my point had a hundred pair of glasses
but these are definitely my day-to-day
essential ones right here you could be
looking anywhere you could be sleep I
could be sleep on the air yes
so speaking of essentials we have
ascension this water is 9.5 on the pH
level has electrolytes for the taste and
it's very over achieving h2o you know
maybe we can do a bottle you know my
face in the inside of it
I'm hologram or something like that you
know to me do a nice collab but you go
to my house this is all I sent my fridge
I have a whole fridge full of it and I
have like a whole cabinet so it's like
you know some people like room
temperature some people like ice cold me
I like room temperature water I
Scholz but it's not good for you right
here we have another day-to-day
essential which I keep my passport in
credit cards and oh this is my red card
for the win gambling you don't say when
you gamble a lot you got a lot of these
four different casinos it's like I got a
a Barney's gift card that probably would
never used probably expired so this is a
Louboutin I turned it into a passport
well I don't know if it's a passport
holder but to lose the time collab with
Murakami and it's crazy because I
actually lost the same passport before
and it was hard to find and I actually
found another one so whoever found mine
please report it get it back yeah I'm
gonna have like my driving license on me
but I'm just so used to always traveling
especially out of the country that I
always have my passport I actually have
a matching ring for this wallet you can
check it out right here
so this is definitely another day-to-day
essential car mix you know I'm saying
cuz uh you gotta keep your lips right
and I'm saying you can be you know I
think that's the first thing that most
people look at is right like your teeth
when you talk or your mouth so I try to
keep my lips more especially if I'm
speaking to like you know ladies gonna
mean we got to do a collab or something
let's do like teitelbaum or something
like that each other shout out to car
mix man it's gonna come back pop so that
was it for today those are my 10
essentials thank you for watching
[Music]